First of all, there is a phrase by
Milton Friedman that seems sublime to me
regarding these issues, which is when you
put equality above
freedom. You don't end up achieving
either of the two. When you put
freedom above equality,
you achieve many of them.  both there precisely
precisely the point Which is that
Social justice is
unfair there is nothing more Unjust than
social justice you are going for the issue of
social justice which is the redistribution
of income you deep down what you are
doing is using the
repressive apparatus  of the State to take away the
successful to distribute it at whim
depending on what the one in
the
armchair wants. liis is but it has Nothing to
hurt with the Modern progressivism andm
and social Justice movement and all that